Hey, everybody. Welcome
to "Corrections: Remote."
Because I am vaccinated...
but not Jacksinated --
vaccinated against Jackals.
We are gonna do Corrections
here in a stranger's apartment.
Um...
This is basically
a month's worth of Corrections
because the last one we did
was right before Christmas.
And pretty -- pretty big boner
by me early on,
saying that the "Mona Lisa"
was painted by Michelangelo,
when a lot of you seem to think
it was da Vinci,
but they're pretty --
they're pretty hard
to tell apart, those two.
I mean, especially when they're
not wearing their bandanas.
You know who
my hero in a half shell is?
Botticelli.
Um, more art-history flubs.
We talked
about Edvard Munch's "Scream."
I said the guy in the painting
wasn't screaming;
he was reacting to a scream.
A very wise, well-informed
Jackal sent me something
I'm gonna read you right now
clarifying exactly what was
happening in that painting.
They wrote, "In fact, Munch
wrote a passage in his journal
prior to the painting.
'I was walking along the road
with two friends.
The sun went down.
I felt a gust of melancholy.
Suddenly, the sky
turned a bloody red.
I stopped, leaned
against the railing,
tired to death
as the flaming skies
hung like blood and sword
over the blue-black fjord
and the city.
My friends went on.
I stood there
trembling with anxiety,
and I felt a vast,
infinite scream
through nature.'"
Overdramatic Munch?
[ Laughter ]
I mentioned Thomas Jefferson...
as an inventor.
And people took issue with that.
They said, "I think
you meant Thomas Edison
or maybe even
Benjamin Franklin."
But I'm here to tell you --
Thomas Jefferson was
a very accomplished inventor.
Polygraph.
Not like a lie-detector
polygraph,
but a poly-- where you can
write a letter in duplicate
'cause the pens were connected.
This is all at Monticello,
the home of limoncello.
And so the polygraph.
The swivel chair
was Thomas Jefferson.
And the Jefferson disc,
which is a CD
that plays "White Rabbit."
[ Laughter ]
There was some confusion
based on something
that happened
in the last Corrections.
I was talking
about the difficulty
of doing
a Hugh Laurie impression
while he was playing House,
because then I have to do
an impression
of a British person
who's then doing an impression
of an American person.
And then I did a Hugh Grant.
People thought I thought
Hugh Grant played Hugh Laurie.
That's just -- That was --
The problem there
is that "Hugh"
is too popular amongst
British actors as a first name.
I know the difference between
Hugh Laurie and Hugh Grant.
You've got Hugh Dancy,
Hugh Bonneville.
There's a lot of Hughs.
There's too many Hughs.
I will say I think
Hugh is a perfect --
It's like a per--
It's the perfect British name
because it sounds like
what the Dowager Countess
would say
if she didn't know a person.
"Have you met Mr. Grant?"
"Hugh?!"
[ Laughter ]
That was pretty good.
Oh, I said the anime series
"Sailor Moon" had been canceled,
and I was assured
by fans of the series
that it was not canceled;
it just completed the story.
This was also true of
NBC's sitcom "Animal Practice."
[ Laughter ]
I said the word "timbre."
I pronounced it "timber."
I did that thing
where I made the error
of pronouncing it
the way it was spelled.
A lot of you said my Ric Flair
impression was bad.
It was terrible,
and I want to apologize
to the Flair family, Flair fans.
What happened is, we --
impression --
Impression camp
had to go to remote,
and it's just -- I just don't
get the same instruction
via Zoom.
And so there's been, um --
There's been a fall-off.
Okay.
I talked about how Ted Cruz
looks like "a Chewbacca."
Chewbacca is not
a species of creature.
Chewbacca is a name.
So shame on me.
That was a Wookiee mistake.
[ Laughter ]
We also showed -- when we were
talking about Ted Cruz,
we showed a skateboard photo
for a skateboard fail.
Can we -- Can we throw
that up real quick, Alex?
And, uh...
someone had -- the criticism
they had of this picture
is that the railing
makes a shadow,
but the skateboarder
doesn't make a shadow.
You know what that means?
He's a Dracula.
[ Laughter ]
Clip It,
better known as Clippy.
Talked about the fact
that he was introduced in 1997.
I was told by many of you
that he was introduced
in Office '97,
but that came out in 1996,
which seems like a correction
Microsoft should be making.
[ Laughter ]
Okay.
We were talking about
how the CDC issued
a travel advisory to Canada.
We mentioned this
in a monologue,
and a lot of you said,
that's not a map of Canada,
that's a map of Georgia.
So I thought, "What?
Why would we put up
a map of Georgia
when we were telling
a joke about Canada?"
And then I went back
and I looked at the joke,
and I realize what happened,
which is the CDC
is located in Atlanta,
so the graphics departments
thought the best representation
for that joke would be
to show the state
that the CDC is in,
because what the graphics
department often is,
is technically correct
and practically irritating.
[ Laughter ]
But that wasn't the worst thing
Graphics got me on.
We talked about how there is a
tree named after
Leonardo DiCaprio
and that that tree
is dating a sapling.
Then we showed a photo
of a seedling, which is, um...
That's not the kind of joke
we're trying to make here, okay?
[ Laughter ]
About somebody
hitting on a seedling.
That crosses the line,
and it shouldn't happen.
Apologize to Mr. DiCaprio
and all the tree enthusiasts
out there
who had to stomach that joke.
Now, in normal times, of course,
what would happen is,
I would march down --
I would march down to Graphics,
and I would, um...
have a word with them,
but we can't do that right now.
I'm here.
No need to tell you that.
And so instead,
I set up a Zoom call
with them.
Now, a lot of people made jokes
about the fact
that you don't have to
wear pants during Zoom calls.
Sure. Right?
You don't.
But the problem with Graphics
is, one, they don't wear pants.
Which wouldn't matter,
except they do all their Zoom
calls standing up.
[ Laughter ]
And they also turn
their mics on
before they turn
on their screens,
and so they make sure --
You don't know what's coming,
but they make sure
you're watching.
You know, I start the Zoom,
obviously pretty angry.
I'm like, "All right, guys,
let's get this started,"
and they're like,
"Are you there?"
I'm like, "Yeah, I'm there.
Let's get this going.
Turn on your cameras."
And then it's just like,
click, click, click,
and you see...everything.
[ Laughter ]
I mentioned that horse pudding,
the flavor was Chocolateriat.
And then, well, you guys,
you can see that the flavor
actually says "original."
And, um, that's on me
because I did not give --
I did not give our
props department enough time.
I asked them to make me
this horse pudding.
And by the time
I asked them to change the label
from original to Chocolateriat,
it was too late.
And this was --
because it was...
Sometimes, again, when you
have meetings in person,
I feel like you
you don't miss as much.
But, again, this was all done
via e-mail and text
'cause I'm not in the office,
and so when I ask them
for horse pudding,
they didn't just, like, buy
chocolate Jell-O pudding
and change the label.
They...
I don't even want to say this,
because, like, if somebody
from PETA is watching,
I find, like, what
they did is disturbing.
[ Laughter ]
I asked them for horse pudding,
and I got horse pudding.
[ Laughter ]
I don't want to talk any more
about what happened.
[ Laughter ]
Okay?
It's been a hard week.
For everyone.
And with that said,
pretty excited
to get back into the studio
on Monday, and...
keep watching,
keep looking for the flubs.
And let's try to make this year,
2022, a big year
with the fewest
corrections ever.
You guys are gonna see me
next week.